hello everybody I have an announcement
the podcast is moving to Spotify I
signed a multi-year licensing agreement
with Spotify that will start on
September 1st starting on September 1st
the entire JRE library will be available
on Spotify as well as all the other
platforms then somewhere around the end
of the year it will become exclusive to
Spotify including the video version of
the podcast it will be the exact same
show I am NOT going to be an employee of
Spotify we're gonna be working on the
same crew doing the exact same show the
only difference will be it will now be
available on the largest audio platform
in the world nothing else will change it
will be free it will be free to you you
just have to go to Spotify to get it
we're very excited to begin this new
chapter of the JRE and I hope you're
there when we cross over Thanks